let's divide 3771
by eight
so and we're going to do a little bit of
long division so the way we set it up so
the first thing we want to do and think
about well does eight go into three well
no eight does not go into three so we'll
keep moving does 8 go into 37 sure 8
times 4 is 37 8 times 5 is 40. so that's
too big so 8 goes into 37
8 goes into 37 four times
4 times 8 is 32
and we subtract and we get 37 minus 32
is
5. and just so you have a little glimpse
of what's actually going on here we're
really saying how many times does 8 go
into three thousand seven hundred and
we're saying that eight goes into three
thousand seven hundred four hundred
times it's four sitting in the hundreds
place and that four hundred times eight
is thirty two hundred and then when you
subtract thirty two hundred from thirty
seven hundred you're getting five
hundred but we'll revert back just the
traditional long division mechanics but
that's what's really going on here eight
when we say 8 goes into 37 four times
we're really saying 8 goes into 3 700
400 times but let's keep going so now we
have this 5 to deal with which is as we
already talked about it's in the
hundreds place so it's really a 500 but
now let's bring on let's bring down
another place value so let's bring down
the seven and let's think about how many
times does eight go into 57 and we're
really thinking about how much eight
goes into 570 but 8 goes into 57
let's see
8 times 8 times 5 is 40 8 times 6 is 48
8 times 7 is 54. so let's go seven times
seven times eight
we've already oh actually i did that
right eight times seven eight times my
multiplication tables are weak it is
eight times so it does go into seven
times but seven times eight isn't 54
it's 56 always have trouble with that
one
it is 56 and so now we subtract again
and 57 minus 56 is one and now we have
one more place value to bring down we
have let me do it in a color i haven't
used yet i'll do blue
we have a 1 to bring down
and now we're literally saying how many
times does 8 go into 11 well 8 goes into
one time
1 times 8 is eight and we are left with
because we have no more places to bring
down
eleven minus eight is three so eight
goes into three three thousand seven
hundred seventy one four hundred seventy
one times and the remainder here is the
remainder here is 3.